hora de la información económica en
France 24 por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañera Daniela Blandón
Daniela bienvenida Buenos días Muchas
gracias Valentina y bienvenida también
Muchas gracias comenzamos nosotros este
espacio en Turquía que hoy anunció un
gran cambio en su política monetaria es
un giro enorme Valentina El Banco
Central elevo drásticamente su tasa de
interés y dijo que iría más allá en esta
que es su primera reunión presidida por
la primera mujer gobernadora de la
entidad Happy ergana Esta es una Clara
reversión de una política que ha sido
muy poco ortodoxa de bajas tasas de
interés del presidente ahí Perdón que ha
sido muy criticada por ir en contra de
la corriente de los demás bancos
centrales y haber desplomado la lira
turca lo primero que hay que decir es
que la independencia de los bancos
centrales es muy común pero en Turquía
esto no sucede Así que las decisiones de
reyecta y perdón son muy pues influyen
mucho en las decisiones de El Banco
Central Este es un cambio drástico como
lo decíamos a finales de 2021 El Banco
Central que suele ser muy independiente
Pues redujo los tipos de interés en
cinco puntos porcentuales estaban en 19%
cayeron al
8,5%, ahora están subiendo en 650 puntos
básicos es decir quedan en 15% para
hacerse una idea de
lo dramático que es este cambio frente a
la política que tenían antes pues los
bancos centrales suben o bajan entre ser
25 puntos básicos o 50 puntos básicos
pero 650 es una cifra enorme la lira
Entonces vamos a mirar el comportamiento
se ha seguido desplomando hoy rompió un
nuevo mínimo histórico está en el dólar
en 24 liras cuando en 2013 era
aproximadamente dos libras con dos
libras que compraba un dólar ahora hacen
falta 24 la meta de los bancos centrales
Entonces es cuidar la economía
afrontando la inflación y el crecimiento
económico en este caso el índice de
precios al consumidor en octubre en
Turquía alcanzó un máximo de más de dos
décadas más del 85% anual una de las más
altas del mundo y se ha moderado hasta
un poco menos del 40% Aunque economistas
independientes dicen que esa tasa es
mucho más alta Bueno una situación
bastante crítica la que estamos viendo
Daniela vamos a cambiar de tema porque
inicio en París es una cumbre de dos
días que busca un pacto financiero
global qué tan posible es un pacto
financiero global pues al menos es lo
que van a intentar hacer los líderes y
organizaciones globales que se reúnen
para forjar forjar una nueva agenda
sobre deuda y financiamiento climático
el anuncio más concreto hasta el momento
tiene que ver con una serie de medidas
que lo que pretenden es ayudar a los
países afectados por desastres naturales
de acuerdo con la agencia especializada
routers Que conoció un borrador de la
declaración del encuentro el Banco
Mundial está llamado a esta iniciativa
que va a explicar a continuación la
secretaria del tesoro de Estados Unidos
los bancos deberían ofrecer a los
prestatarios la opción de agregar
cláusulas de deudas resistentes al clima
sus acuerdos de préstamo para que tengan
una mayor protección se ocurren eventos
relacionados con el clima el banco
también debe fortalecer la movilización
del sector privado
Daniela usted qué plataformas de
streaming USA Bueno yo uso muchas
plataformas de streaming Netflix hbo
Disney y las usa con sus cuentas con sus
contraseñas o compartidas no no Por
supuesto que no yo pago una de mis
primos pagan las otras y nos vamos
no le han bloqueado Netflix no me lo
están intentando bloquear Pero bueno Ahí
vamos Bueno vamos a ver hay otra
plataforma y es Amazon Amazon Prime las
autoridades de comercio están demandando
a esta plataforma por engañar a millones
de consumidores para favorecer su
suscripciones a este servicio de
streaming pues lo primero que hay que
decir antes de ir con el tema Valentina
es que esto no solamente sucede con
Amazon a mí personalmente me ha pasado
con algunas empresas que uno es cliente
pero no del servicio Premium y ellos sin
consultarlo lo inscriben a uno y le
descuentan de la tarjeta de crédito para
que tengan mucho cuidado por decir
cuando usted entra de pronto a un
servicio de estos hay unas unas casillas
donde acepta acepta acepta y muchas
veces ni siquiera estamos leyendo qué es
lo que estamos aceptando Exacto ya
estamos aceptando pagar en este caso
alrededor de 17 dólares mensuales en la
Comisión Federal del comercio de Estados
Unidos acusó al gigante Amazon de
inscribir a millones de consumidores en
este servicio de suscripción paga Amazon
Prime sin su consentimiento Pero eso no
es lo más grave sino que les dificulta
la cancelación según esta comisión
concretamente dice que ha utilizado
diseños de interfaz manipuladores o
engañosos para que los consumidores se
inscriban o renueven automáticamente
este servicio y que se requieren hasta
diferentes para suspenderlo la respuesta
de Amazon es que los clientes aman su
servicio Premium y que su diseño es lo
suficientemente claro y simple para que
ellos puedan acceder o cancelar su
suscripción bueno no nos dicen tampoco
mucho Sí yo también soy feliz pero no
soy feliz con que me cobren sin yo decir
que sí claro tiene toda la razón hoy es
el segundo día de comparecencia del
presidente de la Fed en el congreso
Valentina ayer un Power dará su
testimonio semestral sobre política
monetaria Y testificará ante el comité
bancario un día antes habló de la
inflación y La regulación bancaria en
ese país en el contexto de las quiebras
que hubo hace pocos meses también de una
inflación que se está moviendo la baja
pero que no está en el nivel deseable
la inflación se ha moderado un poco
desde mediados del año pasado no
obstante las presiones inflacionarias
continúan siendo altas y el proceso para
lograr que la cifra regrese al 2% aún
tiene un largo camino por recorrer hemos
estado viendo los efectos de nuestra
política de endurecimiento monetario en
los sectores de la economía más
sensibles a las tasas de interés sin
embargo tomará tiempo que los efectos
completos de esta restricción monetaria
se hagan realidad especialmente en la
inflación Daniela yo sé que ustedes
carnívora no sé cómo le iría con carne
artificial pero en Estados Unidos
aprobaron las primeras licencias para
comercializar este producto pues
Valentina no soy muy amante de los
productos artificiales sin embargo Pues
el departamento de agricultura de
Estados Unidos aceptó la venta de estos
productos específicamente carne de pollo
fabricada en laboratorios a partir de
células animales Según los científicos
esto daría paso al ahorro de energía y
de agua que se consumen en grandes
cantidades en la ganadería sin embargo
todavía no está claro de su costo
medioambiental Gabriel colchón nos
cuenta más la carne artificial podría
llegar a nuestros platos Dentro de poco
dos empresas estadounidenses Fueron
autorizadas por primera vez para
comercializar pollo hecho en laboratorio
la carne cultivada en pocas palabras es
carne real que se procesa con células
animales Así que imagina la carne que
hemos amado y comido durante decenas de
miles de años la carne que cultivamos es
en realidad biológicamente la misma pero
se hace de una manera totalmente nueva
la carne artificial de pollo se produce
cultivando células extraídas del animal
o de un huevo de gallina dichas células
se alimentan con nutrientes similares a
los que ingieren los animales como
proteínas grasas azúcar o vitaminas así
las células se desarrollan como lo
harían en el cuerpo del animal y se
convierten en tejido muscular y grasa
para muchos la producción de carne
artificial permitiría reducir de
medioambiental de la ganadería intensiva
hoy con el mundo como está con
poblaciones crecientes con presión sobre
nuestro sistema hídricos sobre nuestra
tierra necesitamos algo mejor una forma
más limpia más segura y pensamos que la
idea de proporcionar a la gente la carne
que les gusta sin matar al animal sin
toda la Tierra y los recursos podría ser
un buen camino para ayudarnos a comer
mejor en el futuro
según la agencia estadounidense
responsable de la seguridad alimentaria
la carne de cultivo no presenta ningún
peligro para el consumo humano sin
embargo es cara y cumple cada de
producir además no se conoce el impacto
medioambiental exacto de este
procedimiento según un estudio reciente
de una universidad de California la
carne de laboratorio podría exigir mucha
energía y emitir importantes cantidades
de gases de efecto invernadero e incluso
más que la carne tradicional Pues nos
impresiona Daniela pero este es el
futuro a usted muchas gracias por esta
ampliación económica aquí nos vemos en
una hora Valentina